before we begin today I would just like
to State for the record that I have no
information in my possession that could
ever lead to the arrest of any Clinton's
even though Hillary Clinton is indeed my
third cousin once removed I know
absolutely no incriminating information
please Hillary please I have a family
and I just I just got married like a
year ago and I we will analyze the
suicide of Jeffrey Epstein that took
place early Saturday morning that was
obviously a suicide and nothing else at
the Manhattan Correctional Center then
President Trump wrongly gets Hollywood
to cancel a movie about how terrible
liberal elites are transvestite
activists and sexual predator Jessica
Yaniv tries to put more innocent people
out of business
and Joe Biden forgets what years he was
vice president all that and more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
hello hello everybody welcome to the
show today on which we are all Alex
Jones we are all Alex Jones now people I
woke up today
sweet little ELISA turned to me in bed
she said Mac I've made you something for
your show today
and it was this cute little tinfoil hat
because there are a lot of conspiracy
theories going around and the biggest
conspiracy theory that I can tell so far
is that Jeffrey Epstein billionaire
pedophile sex trafficker or all these
things that he just accidentally was
permitted to kill himself in prison
that's to me the least plausible thing
in this jail in this Manhattan
Correctional Center that he just
accidentally whoops too bad that's the
craziest one of all we will explore all
of the theories that are going on and
what I think is the most plausible so
much more to get to but first we have
got to thank our friends over at rake on
rake on earbuds start at about half the
price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market and they sound
just as amazing ray cons 'if if t
wireless earbuds have completely changed
the game they are look we're not going
to talk about all the other kinds of
earbuds on the market you know there's
that one that's like really overpriced
and doesn't feel that great and doesn't
fit in your ear and you can't really
customize it then they're a bunch of
other cheapo ones that just don't really
work ray con completely changes the game
here they are super comfortable by far
the most comfortable earbuds they're
super easy to take anywhere unlike some
of the other wireless options ray con
earbuds are stylish and discreet so they
don't have dangling wires or those
hideous stems you know what I'm talking
about of course they don't just look
right they sound great too I really like
them just in so much as one size doesn't
fit all for everybody if you know what I
mean one size and style one size and
sound ray con it just is this perfect
match of extremely good quality and it
looks good and it feels good that some
of the other guys just don't get you've
got to check it out
this will completely change the game
they have a range of fun colors so it's
not just one color for everybody and
there's an unbeatable price right now go
to buy ray con dot
/ Knowles Kano wles you will get 15% off
your order you're not gonna get a better
deal anywhere else that's ray con-com /
Knowles kena wles for 15% off ray con
wireless earbuds if you've been eyeing a
pair now is the time to get an amazing
deal one more time by Ray Khan calm /
Knowles Cana wles do it right now you
will not regret it
we're all Alex Jones now what are the
possibilities for possibilities as far
as I can see it the first one that he
was accidentally permitted to commit
suicide just incompetence whoops
it happened second possibility he was
permitted to commit suicide but it was
intentional and not accidental third
possibility is that he was murdered you
know someone who looks shockingly like
Hillary Clinton with a mustache and some
sunglasses broke in and choke the guy
before he had a chance to scream and
then fourth the fourth possibility is
that he escaped like a Bond villain and
is on his hidden layer right now on
little st. James Island or I don't know
on his own Space Station or something
plotting how to seed the world with his
DNA and global domination of these
options including the fourth option I
think the least plausible explanation is
that Jeffrey Epstein was just
accidentally permitted to kill himself I
think it's just absurd I think it is
maybe more likely that he is still alive
than he was just accidentally permitted
to kill himself there was a former
inmate at the Manhattan Correctional
Center I mean this is a tough place they
held El Chapo there a former inmate at
the MCC told the press quote there's no
way that man could have killed himself
I've done too much time in those units
it's an impossibility between the floor
and the ceiling is like eight or nine
feet there's no way for you to connect
to anything you have sheets but their
paper level not strong enough he was 200
pounds it would never happen
that's his take now I don't know what
does that guys take worth who knows he
was at the center but we don't know that
much about him I do there's another
aspect to this story which is that his
attorneys were apparently the ones who
got him to
taken off of suicide watch so you'll
remember three weeks ago he tried to
kill himself where it was at least
reported that he tried to kill himself
there was some event that brought him to
the hospital and then he was put on
suicide watch and then was almost
immediately taken off of it we're
getting reports right now from The Wall
Street Journal it was actually his own
attorneys who got him taken off of
suicide watch which would lead one to
conclude that he perhaps did kill
himself but it was planned and he was
paying people off to let him kill
himself or his attorneys were were
insisting that he'd be permitted to kill
himself what do we know we don't know
very much we know
that Jeffrey Epstein was a billionaire
sex trafficker and financier with dirt
on some of the most powerful people in
the world including possibly two US
presidents definitely he was very good
buddies with Bill Clinton and he was
friends with Donald Trump before he
became president we know that he very
possibly had dirt on the Duke of York
Prince Andrew we know that he had dirt
on a seemingly endless string of
billionaires what kind of dirt are we
talking about we're talking about dudes
having sex with underage girls we're
talking about the worst-possible dirt
you can possibly have what else do we
know we own we know he owned a private
sex slave Island and he owned the
largest private residence in Manhattan
so he wasn't just rich
he wasn't even just rich by Manhattan
standards he wasn't just rich by having
the largest private residence in
Manhattan standards he also owned his
own private island in the Caribbean that
is a level of rich that is difficult for
most people to comprehend but what's
even weirder about it is we have no idea
how he got his wealth guy was a college
dropout a dropout out of Cooper Union
which is like an art school in New York
and an engineering school he then was
hired despite no qualifications and no
college degree to teach math at an elite
Upper East Side private school gets even
weirder
turns out the headmaster of that school
was Donald bar William Boras father the
current Attorney General his father was
the headmaster at the school that hired
Jeffrey Epstein to teach math even the
we had no college degree and no
credentials whatsoever then after
teaching math of that school for two
years he leaves to take a job with Bear
Stearns a major financial firm how did
he get the job at Bear Stearns one of
the reports that's coming out is that he
met the chairman of Bear Stearns while
he was at that school so he goes there
he works at Bear Stearns for a while
which were Stearns by the way already a
super shady firm that was leading the
pack on the financial crisis he left
that firm under shady circumstances we
don't know the circumstances of his
departure then he starts his own hedge
fund ostensibly we don't I don't know
that's the story is that he started his
own hedge fund but he kept his business
very private so big people on Wall
Street say they never did any business
with him they never really saw the guy
doing business on Wall Street we don't
know really who any of his clients where
he kept all of that a closely guarded
secret but he called it a hedge fund at
least then he's pops up he's friends
with all these powerful people just
coincidentally he's invited into all
these incredibly famous and powerful
circles hobnobbing with presidents and
by the way not just after Clinton left
the Oval Office
but as early as the early 1990s okay
Denny Lee then then the next time we
really hear from him once he starts
Clinton starts traveling around on
Epstein's private jet there are some
articles about him New York magazine for
instance and you have all these rich and
famous people talking about how their
pals with Epstein Trump gave a quote to
it this was obviously before Trump was a
politician and he said yeah I know
Jeffrey's a terrific guy Jeffrey Epstein
was apparently a neighbor in Palm Beach
and a member of Moreh Lago
said yeah they say Jeffrey likes
beautiful women almost as much as I do
and many of his girlfriends are very
young now I obviously I don't think this
is evidence that Trump knew that Epstein
was trafficking underage girls because
if Trump did know that the one thing
that Trump wouldn't have done is give
that quote to the magazine right you
probably just saw Epstein at these
parties with like pretty young girls 21
22 and gave that quote but I'm pretty
certain that if he knew that Epstein was
shuttling fourteen-year-old girls all
around the world
the one thing Trump wouldn't have done
is talked about it to a magazine then he
gets pinched Epstein gets pinched
2007 for soliciting a minor we know that
he had been recruiting all of these
girls I mean some of the girls who had
been recruited by him said that they
were pulling in 8090 girls that Epstein
had these girls in his house and on his
Island every single day some of them
were not allowed to leave according to
stories from the girls but he gets
pinched because a woman in Palm Beach
called the police and said this creepy
dude Jeffrey Epstein solicited my
teenage stepdaughter to give him a
massage and I want you to look into him
so he gets pinched on this obviously
they start to uncover everything and
then this is what's really bizarre he
gets a sweetheart deal so he doesn't get
these federal charges he doesn't go to a
federal prison he doesn't get caught as
a sex trafficker despite the US Attorney
Alex Acosta looking into this all of a
sudden it becomes a local matter and he
gets a year in a private wing of a Palm
Beach County Jail where he gets to leave
for 12 to 16 hours a day six days a week
and go to his own private office what on
earth is that about well reports come
out that then US attorney on the case
Alex Acosta who became Trump's labor
secretary told the White House when he
was interviewing for the labor secretary
oh yeah that Epstein deal I had one
meeting about Jeffrey Epstein and I was
told that he was above my pay grade and
to layoff because he belonged to
intelligence so now you have stories
coming out from the people who were
there at the time and serious federal
employees who were saying yeah he
belonged to intelligence so there's the
suggestion that Jeffrey Epstein sex
trafficker had some relationship with
some intelligence agency then this year
over ten years later he gets arrested on
sex trafficking charges in New York goes
to this jail to Manhattan Correctional
Center really tough jail three weeks ago
he's brought into the hospital for
allegedly having committed suicide then
he somehow goes off of suicide watch
just days later days after this attempt
he's one of the most important prisoners
in the entire country they just take him
off of suicide watch
then this is what gets even crazier his
cellmate who was supposed to be watching
him because he was he was obviously a
suicide risk gets transferred out of his
cell on Friday hours before his death
then the guards who were supposed to be
checking on his cell every 30 minutes
and if he were on suicide watch every 15
minutes
don't check on him once for hours then
we find out just conveniently there's no
camera pointing in his cell so you can't
see any of this happen then even more
coincidentally by the way the news of
his death the apparent suicide took
place Friday night into Saturday morning
the absolute bare bottom of the news
cycle the time when you dump information
what that you do not want to be covered
another coincidence what are the odds
totally crazy huh oh by the way the
medical examiner who's doing the autopsy
which is apparently being supervised by
one of Epstein's lawyers guys has not
yet reached a conclusion so the suicide
the the autopsy rather took place but so
far there has not been a conclusion
we've been joking about this for weeks
and culture tweeted out when he went to
that jail that he should be moved to a
supermax prison before he wound up
mysteriously suicided I said it was
likely that he would commit suicide with
two bullets to the back of the head this
was the joke we've been telling
everybody for months now this guy should
have been on suicide watch 24/7 with a
guy in a camera focused right on him
constantly in a padded cell with cameras
everywhere at this point I would not
even be that surprised if the guy were
still alive you know crime is a function
of means motive and opportunity
there were some of the most powerful
people in the world who wanted Jeffrey
Epstein dead were disappeared and they
had all three the worst part about this
is it's going to fall down the memory
hole
I mean people aren't even tweeting about
it anymore it's like 48 hours later if
people are gonna forget about it there
will be no answer to this because now
he's dead so anybody can say anything
now the investigation should go on the
only way that you could try to get some
justice in this is to pinch his former
business partner this woman ghyslain
Maxwell who is a socialite whose father
was kind of a shady character that had
ties to foreign intelligence
she was apparently the one procuring a
lot of the girls she's just walking free
right now so she's obviously the one
that the people should be looking at now
she should probably be held in a
supermax prison until we have some
answers out of her but it I suspect
we're not going to get any answers even
if right now the most plausible theory
is that he did kill himself and yet he
was permitted to either because of
bribes or because of corruption or
because the attorneys fought very hard
for it and somehow the jail was
convinced to do it even if that happened
that's the most plausible theory we're
probably never gonna get answers into
this case if Hollywood were to make this
story the script would be rejected it
would be too on-the-nose I mean this is
the Hollywood movie whatever happened to
Jeffrey Epstein I suspect we will never
ever know but please don't let that stop
you from theorizing please send in your
your favorite theories on this I'll keep
my tinfoil hat on with me for the rest
of the day and I look forward to hearing
what you have to think coz I put a poll
up and put it on Twitter and within
about 20 minutes it stabilized I said do
you think Jeffrey Epstein committed
suicide yes or no 89 percent said no 11
percent said yes and this stabilized
this for now I mean it's got per a 20 or
30 thousand votes and it's stayed the
same and then my friend Jason Jason ran
over at Katie th in Seattle he said I've
got a better poll did Jeffrey Epstein
commit suicide no or no and I got on
50:50 as a hundred percent so send in
your theories because I would like to
hear them I hope that Attorney General
William bar can give us some better
theories on that but we'll just have to
wait and see and almost certainly won't
get an answer speaking though of
Hollywood speaking of this Hollywood
movie s quality - all of it awful
stories coming out of Hollywood we will
get to it in a second but first support
for the Michael Nolt show comes from our
friends at rocket mortgage by Quicken
Loans I live in LA you know that it's
impossible to find a house in LA because
the minute you find one at first of all
it's like 10 trillion dollars and it's
just this totally opaque home buying
process and then worst part of all is
because I'm a millennial I never learned
to any useful hard skills so I don't
really know much about getting a
mortgage I don't know about that process
and for most people the vast majority
buying a home will be the most important
decision you ever make when I find my
house
and you find a house when you're about
to make this huge decision finding the
right mortgage can be easy because
rocket mortgage makes it easy their
mortgage experts number-one goal is to
make the home buying process smoother
for you
industry-leading online lending
technology rocket mortgages there with
award-winning client service and support
every step of the way
they're ranked highest and customer
satisfaction for primary mortgage
origination 9 years in a row and they're
ranked highest and mortgage servicing 5
years in a row when you work with them
you get more than just alone because
rocket mortgages more than just a lender
when you're about to make the biggest
financial decision of your life don't
just go with some Joe Blow on the street
go with the best go with the guys who
are constantly being rated the highest
they can make it easy they're the top of
the line don't make a big mistake when
you're talking about your financial
future and not just your financial
future your home get started online at
rocket mortgage com / Knolls knr wles
go there right now Equal Housing lender
licensed in all 50 states and MLS
consumer access org number 30 30
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button get mortgage very easy speaking
of Hollywood Hollywood has made some
huge mistakes in the past 48 hours
Hollywood had almost as bad a weekend as
Jeffrey Epstein maybe not quite as bad
but almost as bad there is a movie out
called the or it's not out but it should
be at it's called the hunt it was a
horror movie about this group of liberal
elites you know the kind who run in the
Jeffrey Epstein circles who one weekend
every so often they'll go out and kidnap
deplorable z' and hunt them for sport
could kidnap regular old good apple pie
eat and fourth of July 11 Americans good
ol conservatives and put them in a field
somewhere and hunt them for sport here
is the trailer for the movie your idea
is incredible they can't argue with that
we pay for everything so this country
belongs to us
it's just business panting human beings
for sport
there are not human beings every year a
bunch of the leads kidnap normal folk
like Gus where'd they get you from fly
only Mississippi Lando and hunt us for
sport hurry hurry so it's true we're
being hunted so it looks pretty good
right apparently not
president Trump came out against this
movie he said quote the movie coming out
is meant to inflame and cause chaos they
create their own violence and then try
to blame others and this created a
little bit of an outrage on the right
though I don't I actually didn't see a
ton of this which is the right said how
dare you make a movie about liberal
elites hunting us this is awful this
except that's not what the movie is
about right this is a revenge movie this
is a horror movie
so pretty clearly the the good guys are
the deplorable good old conservative
Americans and the bad guys are the
liberal elites if anything this is like
a fever dream fantasy of how
conservatives view the world it seemed
great I was called on a TV show on
Thursday or Friday and they said I
Michael you got to react to the movie
the hunt and I think they expected me to
be outraged by it I said oh it looks
great looks really good they say you
don't want to cancel it I said no I
wanted to come out it look first of all
Hollywood produces a ton of tripe these
days pretty much the only movie they
make are the same superhero movie again
and again and again so I thought Oh
finally something interesting but also
this is a movie for conservatives it's a
movie that affirms what we believe the
liberal elite thinks about us which is
that they're the worst people in the
world and that they hate us which that
is certainly my view of things and then
it's a movie where the deplorable zand
the Conservatives go out and get revenge
against the bad guys cool works for me
but now it's being cancelled and it's
being cancelled I think input not
entirely because of conservatives not
entirely because Trump called Hollywood
out for it I think a lot of it too is
because of the shootings a week ago
Hollywood doesn't want to seem like
they're in flaming and calling for
violence against conservatives but that
doesn't seem to be what the movie was
doing anyway
and it drives me crazy because about
once a year there's a movie from
Hollywood that I actually want to go see
you know in the last few years what we
had a quiet place we had Hail Caesar get
out was kind of interesting but those
are the exceptions most of the movies
were horrendous
so you finally see a movie that looks
pretty good and then it gets canceled
this is the problem with cancel culture
this is the problem which is 99.9% a
leftist problem but occasionally
conservatives get involved too which is
we don't like you we're gonna shut you
down we're gonna shut you up or we think
we don't like you so we're gonna shut
you down and shut you up bad idea just
let it out
it's okay they'll make a movie if
Hollywood wants to make a bad stupid
liberal movie people aren't gonna go see
it Hollywood wants to make what seems
like a fairly conservative movie I bet
people would have gone to go see it but
you don't have to go see it if you don't
want to now it's not just this movie
it's not just the hunt unfortunately -
this is a tough day I'm having almost as
bad a day as Jeffrey Epstein - because
not only do I have to defend Hollywood I
have to defend Sarah Silverman one of my
least favorite comedians if you can even
call her a comedian but she apparently
she was relating this on a podcast Sarah
Silverman apparently just got fired from
a movie because on her own unfunny TV
show
she wore blackface one time I don't
watch your show I didn't watch the
episode I don't know the context of the
blackface but I assume she wasn't
wearing it just to make fun of black
people I don't think she was going out
there I don't know that she was singing
al Jolson songs or something assume she
was doing it for a comedic point to make
some kind of point and yes she was fired
from a movie for it so my question is is
Jimmy Kimmel been fired yet from his
show Jimmy Kimmel wore blackface on the
man show has Ted Danson been fired from
his incredibly good and successful
career in Hollywood yet Ted Danson wore
black face one time to make a point
about Robert Downey jr. he wore black
face in that movie Tropic Thunder
how about Julianne Howe I don't even
know who that is but she's apparently a
Hollywood person she wore blackface
about Fred Armisen from Portlandia and
SNL he wore blackface on us and
about gigi hadid how about the governor
of Virginia Ralph Northam who either
wore blackface or a KKK hood probably
the latter but he hasn't copped to
either of them who was just on his
medical school yearbook page why are we
firing one person for this when we're
not firing other people doesn't make a
lot of sense also
are we really going to take away
someone's career because they wear
blackface I get I guess if you're gonna
do that though if that's the new rule
then you got to apply it to everyone and
are we gonna take away the Wayans
brothers careers because they were white
face in that movie white white girls or
white chicks remember that movie it was
two black guys who put on white face and
blond wigs and they pretended to be
white girls so you're allowed to do that
but you're not allowed to wear black
face or I guess you're allowed to wear
black face it for virtually every
liberal elite in Hollywood except for
Sarah Silverman
I hate defending Sarah Silverman but I
have to do it because it's just not
applied fairly there's no logic to this
cancel culture there's no logic to these
new speech codes there's no logic to
political correctness it isn't a logical
ideology political correctness is a
cudgel that's all it is it's just a tool
it's just a hammer used to smack down
your opponents which is why it only
happens to some people and not others
you know megyn kelly for goodness sakes
she was on that show it and on NBC and
she suggested that wearing blackface
isn't the worst possible crime
especially let's say if you go out and
go as Diana Ross let's say for Halloween
and you darken your skin a little bit to
look more like Diana Ross maybe that's
not the end of the world maybe you
shouldn't get fired for that and she
lost her show for that even though other
people on the same network have worn
blackface multiple times but nothing
happens to them now why did they go
after Megan did they go after Megan
because of her comments about blackface
absolutely not they went after Megan
because they don't like her politics
because they're not exceedingly
left-wing and they went after her
because they didn't like her show so
they were looking for an excuse to get
rid of her show and they used that
political correct excuse as a way to do
it but it wasn't about
suppose it wasn't about values it wasn't
about logic nothing and that is always
the way political correctness is applied
I mean you can even see this in the term
queer so the other day the PC police
that guy at Vox Carlos Mazza that little
bully fascist wanted to get steven
crowder kicked off of youtube because he
used the word queer we were then told
that queer is the new n-word it's akin
to a racial slur even though it's part
of the acronym LGBTQ you'd think if it's
part of the acronym that people are
using to describe themselves and that
other leftist politicians who are not
LGBTQ are using to describe LGBTQ people
you'd assume it's fine but no we were
told it's the n-word I went on a
television show
they actually bleeped out the word queer
queer okay okay so I guess we're not
allowed to use the word queer anymore
except then not three weeks later
Colorado State University released its
PC language code called the inclusive
language guide and it said we're not
allowed to use the word homosexual so
when you can't use queer I guess you're
supposed to use homosexual but now we're
not allowed to use the word homosexual
because that's offensive and the word
that it suggested we use instead of
homosexual is queer so now you say queer
and if you say homosexual you get banned
but three weeks ago you say homosexual
and if you say queer you you get banned
this is not about being able to use the
proper term or civility or politeness or
manners what this is about is constantly
changing the proper word so that you
have to check it's about constantly
having to go to the Orthodox leftist
Committee and say what word am I allowed
to say this week it's about them keeping
it random then keeping it ambiguous so
that when they want to get you they can
get you blackface wasn't a problem for
Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Fallon Ted Danson
here there was a little uproar with Ted
Danson but he survived it wasn't a
problem for gigi hadid wasn't a prob
Sarah Silverman they're gonna get Sarah
why I don't know they just wanted to get
her that's that's the problem and it's
funny in Sarah Silverman's case and I
guess in most of those people because
they are leftists so they do subscribe
to this but I think finally some people
especially comedians are feeling the
pinch of that they said gosh this isn't
great
gosh maybe this isn't about politeness
maybe this is just about getting us all
to shut up speaking of people who should
shut up we'll have to get to the
complete extreme of this absurd leftist
PC culture which is that transgender
activist that sick sexual predator man
Jessica Yaniv who is a transvestite who
tried to get Miss beauticians in Canada
to wax his genitals and then put them
out of business when they wouldn't do it
yeah he's now come out he's going after
a restaurant for the same thing we'll
see what that says about our culture
then we'll get to Joe Biden who doesn't
remember when he was vice president
we'll get to Anthony Scarah Moochie the
mooch turning on President Trump and
hopefully a little bit more but first
you've got to go over to Daley wire.com
because you are almost out of time to
purchase tickets to our backstage live
show on August 21st at the incredible
Terrace theater in Long Beach California
what's the show gonna be Ben Shapiro
daily wire god-king Jeremy boring Andrew
Clavin and most importantly of all me
we'll be chopping up the winners and
losers of politics and pop culture
festival we will be answering your
questions from the audience get them now
they are running out especially the VIP
packages tickets are available at daily
wire.com slash backstage there's still a
few VIP ticket packages available that
includes premium seating photos and meet
and greets with each of us as well as a
gift from Ben much more they're selling
fast so go to daily wire.com slash
backstage get yours today so much more
to get to we'll be right back
so this guy who now goes by the name
Jessica Jessica
yaniv the one who wanted to force
immigrant women to wax his genitals and
then put them out of business when they
wouldn't he's made this sixteen
complaints against beauty salons that
won't wax his genitals he now has a new
grievance which is he went into a place
called New York fries and he said they
refused him service because he's
transgender now the restaurant denies
this and he's a complete lunatic and a
bad person so I don't believe him and I
do believe them
here's unis of telling the story the way
I put it is you're refusing access
you're refusing access to a server like
I was at Pacific Center Mall and I went
to New York fries and this is gonna be
on my next human rights complaint but I
asked for some some fries and they
literally said not for you sir you're
you're transgender to put it like that
I'm sorry who said that New York fries
you're in here in Vancouver yes totally
that totally happened right yeah there's
no way that this lunatic is just making
it up right this insane looking sounding
and behaving person
he's probably believable right probably
not you know if this guy didn't exist
the right would have to invent him I'm
not even convinced that he's not just
some right-wing performance artist but
the trouble is that the left is taking
of seriously and and which shows the
whole point
this guy is a crazy person he's also a
sexual predator apparently who was
preying on underage girls he should be
receiving psychiatric treatment he
probably should be in a straitjacket in
a padded room but he's not actually in
our culture our insane society is
insisting on the fantasy that this guy
is the normal one and they're insisting
that those of us who say otherwise are
the lunatics they're getting it exactly
backwards which they often do some one
who is a guy who wears dresses in public
is not playing with a full deck I don't
mean to make fun of them but if you're a
man and you're wearing dresses in public
something has gone on in your
Saiki that is not quite right and you
probably should get some help and get
your head screwed on straight
someone who pulls the sort of stunts
that this guy is pulling trying to get
all these businesses shut down trying to
force women to fondle your genitals
probably not playing with a full deck
probably needs a little bit of
psychiatric care but we are told by the
left in the name of compassion that we
must pretend that this is all perfectly
normal for this bizarre man to try to
cosmetically make himself look like a
woman and then go in and try to ruin all
these businesses and try to force poor
immigrant women to access genitals we
are told that we have to pretend this as
normal we have to call him a woman we
have to pretend that his male genitalia
are actually somehow secretly female
genitalia and if we don't do that we're
bigots who is this compassionate toward
who because the left is telling us we
have to say all those things or else
we're not compassionate we're mean were
cruel were nasty there are the
compassionate ones who is this
compassionate toward this guy Jessica
Yaniv is an international punchline he's
an object of ridicule rightly so I mean
it's you can't this is the sort of
emperor has no clothes thing like we all
know it we all know that people aren't
supposed to do that and no matter how
many leftists Cold's tell us this is
normal and you're mean if you don't
think it's we just know because we're we
have eyes you know and you can't tell us
not to believe our lyin eyes is this
compassionate toward the immigrant women
that he's targeting and putting out of
business is this compassionate toward
the little girls that he's sexually
traumatizing who benefits from this none
of the people involved benefit from this
most especially him he doesn't benefit
the only people that benefit are the
leftists who are pushing the narrative
the only thing that is being helped by
this the only object that is receiving
compassion is the leftist narrative
because we are being told with gritted
teeth that we can't expose the leftist
narrative for the lie that it is but we
have to I mean this guy is the logical
conclusion of that you have to be able
to
look at him and say you shouldn't be
doing that you're not right in the head
you need psychiatric care men aren't
supposed to wear dresses in public and
force immigrant women to wax their
genitals that's just not that's not how
you're supposed to behave you have to
acknowledge moral realities realities of
behavior biological real you have to
acknowledge reality and the left doesn't
want us to they want us to deny reality
but too bad we have to actually these
days it actually takes courage to say
about that guy you're not supposed to be
doing that because you could have your
you could be labeled transphobic that's
the new one or homophobic or this phobic
or that phobic you got to do it you have
to do you've got to stand up for reality
you might hurt you in an insane society
but I would rather stand up for the
truth and have a bunch of lunatics call
me crazy then go along with the insane
crowd and by the way the great majority
of people know that this kind of
behavior is insane and they're being
bullied by a very small group of leftist
ideologues but if we all call them out
we're going to win speaking of people
not playing with a full deck turns out
that the leader of the 2020 Democratic
presidential primary Joe Biden
apparently doesn't remember what years
he was vice president of the United
States
here's Biden i watch what happened when
the kids from parkland marched up to and
I met with him and then they went off to
up on the hill I was vice president they
went off the hill to go into those
neighborhoods all those congressmen were
like no I'm not here I'm not here don't
tell him I'm around
he watched when he was a vice president
he watched the reaction of the parking
lunching except the Parkland shooting
was in 2018 that was last year and he
hadn't been vice president for six years
at that point where he hadn't been oh
I'm sorry wasn't six years now I'm
pulling a Joe Biden too he hadn't been
vice president for two years at that
point but he had he got elected ten
years before that Ryan he was elected
vice president 2008 he was vice
president for eight years 2016 he was
not vice president what was he doing he
wasn't running for president he was
sitting around and then apparently full
to
later he thought that he was still
vice-president I actually gosh I've had
to defend Hollywood today I've had to
defend Sarah Silverman now I have to
defend the head of Media Matters Parker
Malloy I hate to do it but Parker Malloy
head of that awful disgusting scum of
the earth organization Media Matters
tweeted out when he said that he
actually this was another issue that
Biden's another cognitive issue Biden
referred to Teresa may the former UK
prime minister as Margaret Thatcher who
was the prime minister in the 1980s and
Parker Malloy tweeted and said this is
really not a good sign she said in what
world is a clearly sundowning candidate
the best person for the job
there are 20-plus people to choose from
who aren't currently experiencing
cognitive decline people are acting like
he's already the nominee and the options
are a choice between him and Trump WTF
if you nominate someone who can serve
two terms advantage of having an
incumbent running for re-election it's
worth noting that Biden would be 86
years old by the end of his second term
and that's not to say that old is bad
necessarily but if you see someone
slipping like this now where will they
be in eight years she's absolutely right
Biden is not playing with a full deck I
don't know that that's gonna rob him of
the nomination I mean the question right
now is as he slips and he is slipping in
the polls will the other candidates be
able to rise up and grab him and beat
him in the polls fast enough before they
decide the nominating contests I mean
it's still anybody's campaign right now
but he's been able to hold his lead he
might be able to hold it a little while
longer and then he might forget what he
won in the first place when he wins the
nomination I also have to get to this
before we leave today big news story
everybody's gone after Trump for it
which is that Anthony scaramouche II
former White House communications
director albeit for 11 days is coming
out and he's turned on Trump and he said
Trump should be replaced for 2020 he
shouldn't be the GOP nominee he's awful
he's doing terrible things and we need
to get rid of him here's the mooch on
CNN last week when I asked you if he was
still supported in the answer was yes
this morning when I asked you if you're
calling for a change at the top of the
ticket you said it should be considered
so are you no longer as of this morning
it should be worry
neutral I'm now in an I'm a Republican
so I'm not switching parties to support
a Democrat I believe in the values and
the policies of the Republican Party but
I'm now neutral on the president you're
now knew how to continue to act and if
you now oh absolutely you have to you
have to get into a neutral position and
remember you are no longer an active
minded you are no longer a Anthony I
just I just don't want to pass this by
so people you are no longer an active
supporter of President Trump in his
reelection bid yeah I think that's I I
think that's pretty obvious from over
the weekend I mean the guys actually
dissembling a little bit and he's
sounding more and more nonsensical and
you know we're sort of an SSI stew it
and people inside of Washington that's
just President Trump just let them act
like that but you know you're you're
fracturing the institution's and all of
the things that the country stands for
so that's not worth the economic
policies you know that's not worth the
GDP growth which by the way is slowing
down and the stock market is exactly
where it was a year ago okay so this is
now being turned and Trump's former
White House communications director
turns on Trump and he does it on CNN of
all things i I like Anthony scaramouche
II obviously I've had him on the show
he's a nice guy
I think he's a very smart guy I would
like to put this into context though
it's not as though Anthony scaramouche
is this a die-hard lifelong Trump
supporter or a die-hard lifelong
Republican or a die-hard lifelong
conservative or or really that he's been
any of those things for very long the
mooch supported Democratic candidates
most of the time the mooch supported
Hillary and Obama the mooch was a
longtime campaigner to redefine marriage
to include same-sex monogamous unions I
mean he was a big supporter of this for
years and years and years in 2015 after
Trump decided that he was going to run
for president the mooch called him a
quote hack politician whose rhetoric is
quote anti-american and very very
divisive that was after he started to
run he then at the same time told Trump
to cut it out now and quote stop all
this crazy rhetoric how about on
immigration policy on immigration policy
the mooch
always opposed the border wall and was
clear about it during the entire 2016
campaign then before 2016 he said he
hoped Hillary would win and then because
he is a sort of a Republican he's at
least a New York Republican which is you
know a little up in the air on what that
means in the GOP primary he first
endorsed Scott Walker and then he
endorsed Jeb Bush I'm sorry I've said
that wrong Jeb Bush you have to say it
with the exclamation point otherwise you
don't convey what he really was
supporting so he was endorsing two of
trumps primary opponents he said he
hoped Hillary would win the election he
called Trump a hack he opposed Trump's
signature policy which was the border
wall he he said he was anti-american and
very divisive okay now then he came
around and president Trump hired him
anyway and he was communications
director for eleven days and he's
obviously got a relationship with Trump
going back a long ways but the fact that
a guy who's pretty liberal and pretty
left-wing and has supported a lot of
Democrats and has supported the the more
liberal Jeb Bush faction of the
demography the Republican Party it's not
a huge surprise that he would turn on
Trump I mean it's not I'm not even
imputing his motives I'm not saying he's
got some negative motives I'm just
saying or some some suspicious motives
I'm just saying he's a guy who obviously
comes from a more liberal strand of
politics and he doesn't like the Trump
has been very conservative one of the
reasons I was skeptical of Trump in the
primary is that I thought Trump was more
of a liberal and he wasn't going to be
conservative so it's no surprise that
somebody like me would become more
supportive of Trump over time and
somebody like Anthony Sierra Moochie
would become less supportive of Trump
over time it's kind of like a nothing
news story but it's one where they're
the CNN is just breathlessly reporting
it they're so excited to have this story
I don't think it says a whole lot before
we go I also have to mention one bit of
good news you've got this awful
billionaire sex trafficker he gets
suicided or commits suicide in prison
you've got Hollywood making terrible
decisions you've got a former White
House communications director turning on
the president not a lot of great news
but there is some good news coming out
today
which is that the federal government is
now investigating gender ideology the
transgender ideology
as a civil rights violation in
Connecticut this is great news we've
talked about this story before to female
athletes who were high school athletes
in Connecticut have been forced
repeatedly to compete against boys
so biological dudes and guess what
you're gonna be shocked about this one
he unsurprisingly these boys would win
all of their track meets so they would
keep beating the girls out of trophies
and out of Championships and obviously
the end of high school sports is getting
college scholarships and getting
recruited to run for college teams so
this is now being investigated as a
civil rights violation as it should be
the civil rights question here comes
from title 9 which established women's
sports in colleges and in high schools
and it said that there won't be
discrimination on the basis of sex so
the women get to have their own sports
leagues then along comes in the last few
years gender ideology and what gender
ideology and protections on the basis of
sex are fundamentally incompatible you
can only have one or the other why
because what Title 9 says sexual
protections say is that women get to
have their own sports leagues what
gender ideology says is that women don't
get to have their own sports leagues
that men who think that they're women or
who very much want to be women or who
want to dress up like women get to
compete against actual women trouble is
the men are gonna win because the men
are biologically stronger this genuinely
is a civil rights violation this will be
litigated all the way up at the Supreme
Court and we will decide in the country
whether or not we want to protect women
or if we want to protect delusions the
delusions of men who think that their
women are the delusions of women who
think that their men or the delusions
most egregiously of the leftists who
want to tell us that up is down in north
'south and reality isn't reality and
that we shouldn't believe our lyin eyes
that is what's going to be decided this
is a fundamental legal and political
battle over the nature of reality and
over who gets to decide the nature of
reality itself so buckle up that'll be
even more interesting than Jeffrey
Epstein and that whole thing's been
pretty interesting too well let you know
if there's anything more on that front
but something tells me there won't be as
that sue
per villain plots global domination from
his space station or as he rots in hell
that's our show Michael knows as the
magnet all show come back tomorrow we'll
see you then
the Michael Dole show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Danny D'Amico our audio mixer is
Mike Cora Meena hair and makeup by
Jesuit Elvira production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 on the Matt Walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation